Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Not so long ago, we talked about a technique
that enabled us to render stunningly high
quality cloth models in real-time.
It supported level of detail, self shadowing,
and lots of other goodies that make computer
game developers, and of course, my humble
self super happy.
And today, we're going to talk about a technique
that is able to create these highly detailed
cloth geometries for our digital characters.
I have really fond memories of attending to
the talk of the Oscar award winner Steve Marschner
on this paper a few years ago in Switzerland,
and I remember being so spellbound by it that
I knew this was a day I will never forget.
I am sure you'll love it too.
In this piece of work, the goal is to create
a digital garment model that is as detailed
and realistic as possible.
We start out with an input 3D geometry that
shows the rough shape of the model, then,
we pick a knitting pattern of our choice.
After that, the points of this knitting pattern
are moved so that they correctly fit this
3D geometry that we specified.
And now comes the coolest part!
What we created so far is an ad-hoc model
that doesn't really look and behave like a
real piece of cloth.
To remedy this, a physics-based simulation
is run that takes this ad-hoc model and the
output of this process will be a realistic
rest shape for these yarn curves.
And here you can witness how the simulated
forces pull the entire piece of garment together.
We start out with dreaming up a piece of cloth
geometry, and this simulator gradually transforms
it into a real-world version of that.
This is a step that we call yarn-level relaxation.
Wow.
These final results not only look magnificent,
but in a physical simulation, they also behave
like real garments.
It's such a joy to look at results like this.
Loving it.
Again, I would like to note that we're not
talking about the visualization of the garment,
but creating a realistic piece of geometry.
The most obvious drawback of this technique
is its computation time - it was run on a
very expensive system and still took several
hours of number crunching to get this done.
However, I haven't seen an implementation
of this on the graphics card yet, so if someone
can come up with an efficient way to do it,
in an ideal case, we may be able to do this
in several minutes.
I also have to notify you about the fact that
it is considered a crime not having a look
at the paper in the video description.
It does not suffice to say that it is well
written, it is so brilliantly presented, it's
truly a one of kind work that everyone has
to see.
If you enjoyed this episode, make sure to
subscribe to Two Minute Papers, we'd be happy
to have you in our growing club of Fellow
Scholars.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!